All right, everybody, so this is going to be the last course update
this is basically the part two of the course update and
Starting off
I'm gonna teach you a trading model
that is called the juggernaut and
It is basically
If not the best one of my best
Sculping no daily boss trading models
It works on all time frames. So whether it's one minute 30 seconds or five minutes
It will work the same
now
It is very simple and
You must know what an inverse for everybody gap is
So simply what is an inverse for the gap?
So let's assume that we have a fair body gap here, right?
Now price made a higher high higher low and then a higher high
Now inside this higher high we have a fair body gap now when price is here
When price is here, right?
It is still a fair body gap, but if price closes below the fair body gap
Right in this leg this leg closed below this fair body gap that once that happens
It becomes inverse for everybody gap. So remember that
One price went up there. We had a fair body gap
But then it was not respected and it was broken through like this and the candle closed
Notice what I said the candle closed once the candle closes
This fair body gap becomes inverse for everybody gap. All right, so
Now, what is the model?
So we have you know a higher high a higher low and then a higher high
This higher high must have only one fair body gap
So this should not be multiple fair body gaps here, okay?
So in this instance for example, let's say that this right here is the only was the only fair body gap in this leg
All right, and let's say
All right, so we have this really gap we have to wait for information of the inverse really get once the inverse really gap is formed
We can take look to take our entry. So what are the rules number one look for a liquidity sweep?
All right, it could be any liquidity sweep. All right
once the liquidy sweep is done mark out the fair body gap and
Make sure that there's only one fair body gap in the leg that swept the
Liquidity, right? So over here you can see we swept this high over here, right?
and
This leg only had one for the gap
now
What if you're looking at this on one minute, but there are like multiple
Ferebody gaps here what you can do is move higher
So if there are multiple ferebody gaps go to two minute time frame and see if you get one fair body gap
If there are multiple ferebody gaps on two minute time frame
Go to three minute or four minute and keep going higher until you see one ferebody gap
It is very important that there's only one ferebody gap in the leg that breaks the structure or sweeps the liquidity, right?
It is very important now all you're looking for is after liquidy sweep you are waiting for formation of the inverse ferebody gap
Right, and then you're looking to take your entry on the retest or on the body close
So once the body closes you can enter directly or you wait for a retest, all right?
So close in from in virtual gap forms wait for a retest and you target the most
closest low
so this is where the price action is gonna be look below and the
closest low that you see
That is gonna be your take profit one or your entire take profit level or a place where you should be going break even
So let's assume that this low right here was the closest low here, okay?
Now
Once price takes out the slow, right? You can do three things here once it happens
you go break even and target the
Hard time frame draw on liquidity or what you can do is you can take
30 to 40% of your position off here move your stop to break even and
target some other form of higher time from liquidity or a significant level or
You can take your entire take profit level here
But make sure you are getting at least one-to-one restore reward and how would that happen?
I would go short here first off. I will move my stop my take profit level
I will move my take profit level to this level, okay?
Now I will decrease the stop loss key decreasing the stop loss
Right until I get one-to-one
But if my stop is higher than the high over here
I can then reduce it so I can get more restore what out of this range, right?
but what if and
What if the fair value gap was here and this is just an example and there was inverse rule gap, right?
Apologies
So what would happen my take profit level would be here so I would increase I would decrease my stop like that
Until I get one-to-one restore reward, right?
So now we do not have a restop above here
But somewhere around here because we need to get at least one-to-one. Otherwise
Your risk reward and like your total I would say profit factor would be very low, okay?
So make sure you're getting at least one-to-one and then you can hold the trades if you want to till then like the
Significant target level is hit
This is very simple and this is why I call it the juggernaut because it is very quick and it is very powerful
it has over 70% win rate and notice
watch the video again because
make sure first off that there is only one fair value gap, right and
Wait for a formation of IFVG or inverse rule gap and free on the close or on the retest and target this level
now, here's another way to look at it. So
You would get like a
Market structure shift. So now once you get a market structure shift, right this leg right here
Right, you have to look for a single fair value gap inside this leg because now we had swept this low
And we can also consider this as a market structure shift. So previously if I go
Here we had a break of structure, right? And we looked for a free value gap in the
this leg that broke the structure, but if we
With this and now we look at the
At this right we had a market structure shift now
inside
This leg that did the market structure shift or swept the liquidity, right?
You have to look for a singular fair value gap and the singular fair value gap. Let's assume it's right here
All right, you keep going higher you keep going to a high time frame until you see
You know a single fair but you can stay on one minute
And if you see like a single fair value gap from this range high to this range low then you should be good now
All you're looking for is price to close above this level once the price closes this old fair value gap becomes inverse
Fair value gap and from there onwards you're looking to take your entry on the retest and you're targeting the most recent
High or most recent or more the closest the closest liquidity level and that is going to be this high over here
So your entry would be here you stop would go. Let's go. Let's suppose you go along here, right?
first off move your take profit level and
We decrease the stop to till this level and we get 1.33 and we can then hold if you want to take some partials as I said before
Now let me give you guys some examples and then everything is going to be clear